[Musique]
merci farid bensalem de nous aura donné
la définition du game et fille 14 l'ol
qu'est ce que tu nous a concocté pour la
suite
alors pour la suite n'a de notre
troisième speaker je les rencontrais
dans un jeu grandeur nature c'était un
univers de cape et d'épée un peu à la
d'artagnan et j'ai pas tout compris vous
expliquera beaucoup mieux que moi en ce
moment il est en train de créer sa
start-up ce qui en fait il conçoit des
attractions immersive et ludique
et donc grâce à ça il allie ses
compétences d'ingénieur et toutes ces
expériences dans le monde du jeu et du
ludique
donc je vous demande d'accueillir s'il
vous plaît monsieur gilles raymond jour
il ya quelque temps j'étais invitée par
la duchesse de chevreuse à participer à
un petit séjour dans son domaine de
sologne
c'était pour moi simple chevalier
l'occasion inespérée de faire des
relations et de rentrer dans le beau
monde
à peine arrivé sur place je reçois une
missive d'un certain fera sac l'âme
damnée du cardinal de richelieu en
substance le courrier m'invitait à le
croyait m'invitait à enquêter sur les
agissements du baron de valois on de
valois
l'un des ennemis du cardinal de
richelieu au conseil du roi et laissait
entendre que l'homme pourrait avoir des
liens avec l'étranger et agir contre les
intérêts du royaume la lettre se
terminer par une allusion rapide un duel
auquel j'avais participé au cours duquel
je n'avais peut-être pas respecté
l'intégralité des règles de l'honneur
bref
fermement décidée à servir mon pays et
accessoirement éviter que cette
regrettable histoire ne ressurgisse je
décidé d'aller visiter des appartements
du baron de valois qui se trouvait logés
dans le même pavillon de chasse que moi
même vous accompagner par vale ernest
ainsi qu'un spadassins italien du nom de
virginie je profitais que le baron était
en train de faire une partie de croquet
dans l'est dans le parc pour monter dans
les étages
le gardien des lieux rapidement expédiée
par virginie nous pénètre à main dans la
chambre du baron de valois et après une
fouille de quelques minutes nous
découvrîmes un petit coffret
soigneusement dissimulés fermé à clé les
doigts agiles de mon fidèle ernest
venant à bout rapidement de cette ce
coffre et de cette serrure nous mîmes la
main sur un petit une petite liasse de
courrier l'expéditeur et des anglais et
le courrier prouver sans doute possible
que le baron avait fait collusion avec
l'étranger pour soutenir les protestants
protestants qui s'étaient rebellés
contre notre bon roi j'en étais en train
de comprendre la gravité des faits quand
soudain le baron ainsi que plusieurs
hommes à sa solde
surgi sur le palier n'écoutant que mon
courage j'empochais les lettres passer
par la fenêtre et sauter dans le jardin
les sons l'honneur ernest et à l'italien
de couvrir ma glorieuse retraite bien
cette petite introduction cette histoire
elle a eu lieu dans un jeu de rôle
grandeur nature l'histoire s'arrêtait
pas là a continué
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter ce
qu'est un jeu de rôle grandeur nature
je vais aussi vous expliquer en quoi
c'est différent des autres jeux et enfin
un peu à l'instar de farid je vais vous
parler ce que ça implique dans notre
société moderne
donc pour faire un jeu de rôle grandeur
nature il ya trois éléments
indispensables
les organisateurs qui sont des bénévoles
et qui vont poser le cadre pour que le
jeu puisse avoir lieu donc le cadre
c'est un cas de logistique ça va être un
château en sologne
ça va être des couchages ça va être des
repas et après ils vont poser le cadre
ludique
donc c'est un univers là on était dans
du cape et d'épée c'est des règles et
c'est le contexte de l'histoire
les gens sont invités par la duchesse de
chevreuse pour quelques jours et après
les joueurs et des joueurs ils vont
venir ils vont interpréter un personnage
il portait un costume ça c'est six fois
le plus et ils vont interpréter ce
personnage qu'est ce qui constitue le
personnage vous allez avoir une histoire
des compétences par exemple
manifestement vallée ernest savez
crocheter les serrures et il va avoir
une personnalité en personnage n'est
manifestement pas très honorable et pas
très courageux et enfin des motivations
qui vont lui donner une raison d'agir et
l'alchimie sais quoi mais en fait c'est
la rencontre de celles et de ceux cadre
avec les joueurs et les joueurs qui vont
interpréter un personnage faire des
choix en fonction de leur histoire de
leur motivation de leur inspiration du
moment et vous imaginez que pendant 48
heures vous avez 70 joueurs qui vont
faire des choix individuels pour
construire collectivement une histoire
voilà ça c'est le gm je vais vous donner
quelques chiffres pour que vous ayez
l'idée de ce que ça représente en france
donc il ya quand même pas mal de joueurs
il ya beaucoup d'associations l'extrême
majorité des organisateurs sont des
bénévoles
donc il ya beaucoup d'associations
et on voit qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de joueurs alors j'ai comme farid je
vais tendre la question je vais faire un
petit sondage ici qui parmi vous a
participé déjà à un jeu de rôle grandeur
nature faut lever la main on va dire que
c'est un petit peu moins de la moitié
eh ben je vais vous dire que c'est pas
vrai vous avez tous participé à un jeu
de rôle grandeur nature et plusieurs
fois et je le prouve les cowboys et les
indiens les gendarmes et les voleurs
tous les jeux de cet ordre là que vous
avez pratiqué est enfant sont des formes
simpliste primaire on va dire des jeux
de rôle grandeur nature
vous êtes tous des joueurs moi j'ai
commencé jeu de rôle à l'âge de 14 ans
depuis j'entends je participe à des tant
que joueur à des jeunes rôle grandeur
nature depuis 15 ans j'en organise et
dans quelques mois je vais démarrer ma
société qui produit du loisir qui
s'inspire qui dérivent du jeu de rôle
grandeur nature
quand on a ce passé là quand on a ce
passif là à un moment donné on se
retourne un petit peu sur ce qu'on fait
et on se pose des questions
la première question qu'on se pose c'est
qu'est ce que c'est que jouer
qu'est ce que c'est que jouer alors il
ya des définitions pouvez regarder sur
internet et vous verrez que les
définitions sont très variables pour
quelque chose aussi triviale que jouer
et danser assez compliqué à définir donc
moi je vais vous proposer ma définition
jouer c'est s'amuser à expérimenter sans
conséquence
s'amuse et on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
la notion de plaisir elle est cruciale
on va jouer on va jouer parce qu'on
espère éprouver du plaisir
j'irai plus loin ma définition on ne
on ne joue que par plaisir et on ne peut
pas avoir d'autres motivations
donc ça exclut par exemple les joueurs
professionnels ou les jeux d'argent il
ya des gens qui vous en parlerons plus
tard dans la dans l'après-midi à
expérimenter dans le cadre du jeu donc
on va voir des règles enfin convention
qui se posent entre plusieurs personnes
on va expérimenter des choses on va
essayer on va faire des actions les
acteurs et donc on va expérimenter et le
troisième point sans conséquence qui est
aussi un point important c'est que
gagner ou perdre dans un jeu n'a pas de
conséquences hors du jeu quoi qu'il se
passe dans le jeu on n'en ressort pas
blessé on n'en ressort pas en ayant
perdu quelque chose l'exemple type c'est
nos deux enfants qui jouent si abandonné
1 1 qui se fait mal le jeu va s'arrêter
immédiatement sans que on ait besoin de
l'expliquer et c'est naturel une
convention dernière cheveux pour
compléter sa je suis vous parler du fait
que le jeu en fait c'est pas le propre
de l'homme
le rire peut être c'est le propre de
l'homme le jeu non les animaux jouent
tous les animaux jouent et ses niveaux
jeunes en tout cas joue donc cette
notion de jeu elle et elle est
importante elle est assez universel je
vais essayer maintenant de caractériser
le jour grandeur nature et pour ça j'ai
utilisé un modèle qui une des théories
du game design qui s'appelle modèle et
la nes je vais vous expliquer vous
inquiétez pas il ya trois dimensions
dans ce modèle la première c'est le lui
dise non le lui dise ne sait plus facile
c'est la définition habituels qu'on a du
jeu c'est à dire on a des règles c'est
assez formel on a un périmètre bien
clair et on a un challenge qui peut être
un challenge contre
un adversaire ou un challenge contre soi
même donc là les échecs sont un très bon
exemple mais aussi le puissance 4 tous
les jeux de cartes et la plupart des
jeux qu'on dirait classique la deuxième
dimension de ce modèle c'est la
simulation la simulation c'est la
distance qui existe entre votre jeu et
la réalité
donc je vous ai donné l'exemple d'un
simulateur de vol ce simulateur de vol
c'est un jeu ça peut être un jeu mais
surtout c'est quelque chose qui doit
s'approcher au maximum de la réalité
c'est la raison d'être du simulateur le
paint ball par exemple c'est aussi un
jeu qui est très dans la simulation
l'expérience de jouer au paintball est
quand même quelque chose de très concret
de traits réels la troisième dimension
c'est la narration la narration sais
quelle histoire me racontre enjeu donc
l'exemple type c'est le livre dont vous
êtes le héros
c'est vraiment l'archétype vous avez une
histoire vous faites des choix et
l'histoire avance tout le coeur de
l'intérêt d'un livre dont vous êtes le
héros
c'est l'histoire que vous arrivez à
construire par vos choix
il ya d'autres exemples il ya des jeux
vidéos qui sont très axés sur la
narration
il ya d'autres choses comme ça ces trois
dimensions
on peut les représenter dans un triangle
qui vont nous permettre en fait de faire
une carte un petit peu de déjà donc
surprend nos exemples les échecs les
échecs on a dit c'est du ludisme mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir qu'en
fait c'est aussi de la simulation est
aussi la narration
alors un petit niveau pourquoi ces de la
simulation les échecs parce que quand
vous êtes qu'on fait une partie d'échecs
en fait vous gérez une armée c'est la
bataille de deux armées et dans votre
armée vous avez la troupe de base
vous avez des pièces plus forte des
pieds sont à forte et tout ça ça
constitue votre armée vous allez devoir
gérer les forces et faiblesses de votre
armée pour écraser l'armée adverse alors
on est très loin
la simulation et vous voyez qu'il ya des
notions sur l'aspect narration se dire
bac l histoire me raconte une partie
d'échecs
je serais d'accord avec vous sauf que
vous avez deux pièces qui s'appelle le
roi et la reine
pourquoi le roi et la reine parce qu'on
est bien en train de dire que c'est une
bataille entre deux royaumes
la narration va pas beaucoup plus loin
on connaît pas le nom du roi et de la
reine on sait pas de quel pays on parle
on sait pas pourquoi ils se battent mais
il ya quand même le prémice d'une
narration
après on voit ce que ça donne
pour le simulateur de vol et pour les
deux mille euros c'est un peu la même
chose c'est des jeux qui sont ont été
choisis parce qu'ils sont justement très
spécialisés alors pourquoi je vous ai
parlé de ce modèle là et pourquoi je
parle de ce modèle là dans le cadre du
jeu de rôle grandeur nature
ben parce que ce modèle permet
d'exprimer la particularité du jeu de
rôle grandeur nature à savoir qu'il est
très fort sur ces trois aspects le
ludisme est très présent vous avez des
défis vous avez des oppositions
vous avez des règles la simulation est
évidemment très présent vous êtes
physiquement en train d'agir comme votre
personnage et la narration comme on l'a
vu c'est le but même d'un gnc de
construire collectivement une histoire
sur ces trois aspects on voit que le jeu
est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus large
sur cette map on ne peut pas dire que le
jeu est meilleur qu'un autre jeu ça veut
juste dire que ça nous permet de mettre
en avant
qu'est ce qui fait la différence et ça
explique aussi que l'expérience qu'on
vit dans un job à la nature est beaucoup
plus large et beaucoup plus intense que
qu'ailleurs vous avez des challenge qui
vont vous motivez vous avez la
simulation qui fait que vous êtes dans
le concret et vous allez la narration
qui fait que vous êtes emmené dans une
histoire
donc résultat vous allez être emporté
dans cette aventure en est un exemple
que j'ai à ce sujet c'était plusieurs
années je jouais un chevalier
classique médiévale et on défend d une
cité petite ville et tout d'un coup des
barques les vikings donc les vikings ils
arrivent ils sont nombreux ils sont
armés ils sont méchants et ils veulent
en découdre
donc nous on s'organise on se met en
défense et sous la porte
la grande porte de la ville il ya un
front qui ceux qui se constituent les
gens et les boucliers sont devant moi je
suis en deuxième ligne
mais la situation est bloquée parce que
les forçant à peu près équivalente
il ya des boucliers repas contourner
puisqu'on est dans la porte donc la
situation sur ce blog comme ça et tout à
coup il ya gérard qui rentre dans
l'histoire
gérard saint arbalétriers gérard il a
faim il a froid il est fatigué et tout
ça ça le stress résultat il se contrôle
pas et iron qui tient à carreau le
carreau va se planter dans un viking qui
au premier rang ont cédé pas des
carreaux qui blessent
on est bien d'accord le viking pas ça je
suis blessé si bas je vais reculer il
passe au troisième rang comme ça le
problème
sauf que les vikings qui sont à côté de
lui voit un gars qui reculent
instinctivement réfléchissent pas
instinctivement ils font ça
instinctivement nous réfléchit pas on
faisait un steak tivement on avance sur
les vikings victimes ils font ça
instinctivement poursuit des vikings et
20 30 secondes plus tard on était en
train de les poursuivre dans la plaine
au loin
c'était la débandade complète c'était la
panique pourquoi je vous parle de cette
expérience parce qu'elle est assez elle
est assez forte et elle m'a fait
découvrir un élément qu'on ne voit pas
tous les jours qui est un composantes
d'un mouvement de masse
le cerveau humain est super performant
vous le mettez en masse et tout d'un
coup il se passe des choses comme ça je
vais revenir sur la définition du début
et il ya quelque chose qui me gêne c'est
pas la définition c'est l'illustration
parce que là l'illustration c'est que
des jeunes aujourd'hui le jeu ne s'est
pas que les jeunes
ces adultes aussi ça ressemble plutôt à
ça donc pourquoi des gens adultes jouent
à des jeux de plus en plus sophistiquées
de plus en plus complexes je vais
essayer de vous proposer une explication
traditionnellement dans l'ancien temps
depuis l'antiquité tout ça tout ça
la société était très stable on avait un
métier pour la vie et et on la prenait
part en étant apprentis justement c'est
à dire on apprenait en faisant la
situation était très stable
une fois qu'on a fait ça on pouvait
espérer s'en sortir côté des jeux ben il
y avait des jeux c'était un truc pour
les enfants voilà et après les adultes
jouer un petit peu à des jeux mais qui
étaient dans la sphère bien précise du
ludisme 20e siècle est arrivé j'ai
développé un très large 20e siècle est
arrivé les bousculement technologiques
sont arrivés dans la société
donc au niveau au niveau du cadre on
était encore sur quelque chose de stable
tout cas la première moitié du 20e
siècle quand ont commencé un travail on
a été jusqu'au bout
à la fin de sa vie mais par contre on
nous demandait maintenant de monter en
compétences donc monter en compétences
la réponse au delà des apprentis ça a
été les formations initiales les écoles
l'istec par exemple cas les pouvoirs en
quelques années vous former et vous
rendre complètement compétent sur votre
métier que vous allez que vous alliez
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de jusqu'à la
fin de vie du côté des jeux pan déjà on
a beaucoup plus de loisirs et du côté
des jeux il ya des nouveaux jeux qui
sont apparues et qu'ils ont un peu
qu'ils sont un peu déplacé sur le
triangle qu'ils sentent qu'il est plus
que ludique je vais vous donner un jeu
complètement révolutionnaire est
exceptionnel qui s'appelle le monopoly
et le monopoly en fait si vous le
comparez au jeu d'échecs
enfin sur la main sur la complexité du
jeu mais sur sur les aspects de
simulation et narration et bien on est
beaucoup plus loin en simulation en
narration que les échecs
quand on joue au monopoly veut manipuler
des billes et vous êtes sur un principe
de transactions capitaliste simplifiez
vous êtes dans la simulation dans le
monopoly vous acheter des maisons vous
achetez des hôtels voulait placer sur
des rues qui existe même dans la vraie
vie
et pour couronner le tout vous allez en
prison vous êtes dans la narration on
est très loin des jeux de rôles très
loin des jeux de rôle grandeur nature
mais c'est une tendance qui s'amorce
avec ce genre de jeu le vingtième siècle
c'est aussi l'époque où un certain johan
huizinga qui est un sociologue
néerlandais a écrit son livre qui
s'appelle homo ludens et le principe de
qu'il défend dans ce livre c'est de dire
qu'une société qui joue est supérieur à
une société qui ne joue pas je vais
reprendre son propos pour terminer mon
petit exposé en vous parlant
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pour faire
simple c'est le bordel la famille c'est
compliqué le travail c'est compliqué le
cadre le cadre technologique c'est
compliqué tout est compliqué tout change
et on sait pas forcément vers quoi ça
évolue avec quoi on s'adapte à sa pas
toujours aller à l'istec et et
travailler dur pour être compétent mais
faut pas rêver
dans 20 ans ce que vous avez appris
cette année sera en grande partie
obsolète
désolé par contre il ya un atout majeur
qui est sorti de notre poche ça
s'appelle internet
internet c'est formidable ça nous permet
de manière instantanée et quasiment
gratuite d'obtenir une information à la
demande
donc c'est très bien et côté des jeux et
bien en fait on voit arriver ce que moi
j'appelle les jeux de l'expérience donc
les jeux de l'expérience c'est les jeux
de rôle grandeur nature
mais c'est aussi d'autres choses qui ont
été évoquées avant à savoir les escape
room c'est les jeux de réalité virtuelle
et c'est un ensemble de jeux comme ça
qu'on qualifierait dit merci fait
campagne et pur qualifierait des jeux de
l'expérience
ces jeux là ils vont permettre
d'acquérir de l'expérience
donc d'un côté on a une société qui
bouge de plus en plus ce qui est de plus
en plus en plus instable et sur laquelle
on n'arrive pas trop à voir avoir de
prise sait pas trop comment ça va bouger
demain et de l'autre on a des jeux qui
nous permettent d'acquérir de manière un
petit peu aléatoires des expériences
variées mais très intense
de l'autre côté donc est-ce que c'est
pas en complément d'internet en
complément du reste est ce que les jeux
d'expérience sont pas un bon moyen
d'adresser les problèmes de la société
moderne que vous rencontrez tous les
jours et vous donner de l'expérience qui
va vous permettre de faire face à des
défis que vous ne connaissez même pas
sur ce je vous remercie
je vais vous laisser pas ce que je dois
retrouver la baronne de valois qui me
dit on est plutôt d occuper depuis que
son mari a eu des problèmes avec la
justice
[Musique]